i haven't had the pleasure of going to
canton to see the hall of fame
bus and plaques but i have been to the
red sox hall of fame and i have seen the
plaque of our next guest
joe castiglione the voice of the red sox
a dear friend
kind enough to spend some time with us
on a friday
uh and and and chat here on the rich
eyes and so joe it's great to have you
what do you remember about that day
where you were inducted into the red sox
hall of fame
well i remember i was in strange company
that uh probably shouldn't have been
included because
it was roger clemens nomar garcia parr
and pedro martinez so
it was really quite an honor and the red
sox
really do ceremonies right they they
nail it every time
joe we were showing some old photos here
on peacock and there was a picture of me
in the booth with you when i was very
young wearing a jose canseco hat
in the booth at fenway and conseco one
of our favorite follows on twitter
tweeted out today
why do you love baseball just putting an
open-ended question out there into the
world so
i will ask you joe the question from
kinseko's twitter
why do you love baseball well i love the
rhythm of the game i love the people in
it i mean they're
really individualistic and uh there's so
much
uh personality i think that's a big big
factor
uh this is a symmetry of the game i
think
uh you know just so poetic in so many
ways
as long as the pitch is not holding the
ball forever and taking 40 seconds
between every pitch
like we see sometimes today but boiling
it down to its basics
it is a beautiful and poetic
and symmetrical kind of game joker sig
leon the voice of the red sox w-e-e-i
joining the show and we were talking
about the ticker that you guys used to
have in the booth and i remember fondly
always getting the the assignment of hey
can you rip off the ticker and that
thing would print out scores and it
would come down and it would
it would roll up if you didn't rip it
off too often the advancements in
technology
i would imagine from when you started to
now are astounding how has your
broadcast changed you think
from when you began because of all the
new technology in the booth
yeah basically there's so much more
information at your fingertips
then because of the internet and of
course we don't need the ticker anymore
because we have
the internet for up to the second scores
uh but you can look up so many different
facts i mean
not only uh things like hitting with men
in scoring position but
a lot of guys hitting on one two counts
on fastballs
and all that information is out there uh
right at your fingertips so
you don't have to wonder if this
happened or that happened or what's
going on because
you have it right there and i think it
makes for a much more accurate broadcast
in many ways
as long as you don't get too bogged down
in the numbers because
if you do too many stats it's by going
to work for most people so
um stories are always better than stats
i have a story once my first world
series game i got to go
to with joe casiglione which was
incredible because joe you don't i would
imagine you don't get a chance to go to
too many games as a fan
we got to go to game one 1996 world
series braves and yankees
andrew jones hitting two home runs i
think he was a teenager then
still right yeah that's right and so i
would imagine is that is that the only
game you've gone to as a fan was that
the last game you've gone to and sat in
the stands
well i did go to a game uh right around
the all-star break at our new park at
worcester where
aaa club the worcester red sox play the
woo socks as they're called at polar
park
uh and uh that was to see the new park
and some of our
farmhands who could be in the big
leagues soon
and uh that's certainly uh i guess i
went as a fan but i also went to the
2001 world series two in a similar way
because my son
was a sports anchor in new york and had
tickets when they played the yankees
played arizona
but that doesn't happen very often that
i go and sit in the seats but
those were fond memories certainly and
back in 96 we thought the braves were
gonna sweep after that first game it won
the first two games and then lost the
next four
well that's what's so beautiful about
baseball joe is that it's so
unpredictable and if you had told me
growing up after all those nights
heading back into manhattan with you and
my dad on the train when entire subway
cars would chant
boston boston sucks and all the grief my
dad got wearing his hat around midtown
the fact that 20 years later 30 years
later he would have the audacity joe to
say to me after they beat the dodgers in
the world series they should have swept
can you believe that you've gotten to a
place in in your
time with the red sox to have all these
world series rings
and that this actually happened and you
were there to call it
had four world championships in 15 years
that no other franchise can claim as
many
world championships in this century and
uh no you never think of that because it
was 86 years between
world championships we thought we had it
in 86 till
the collapse at shea stadium but uh
this is france has done a remarkable job
of reloading
year after year and it's really a credit
to the ownership group here because you
need good owners
who will be willing to spend and spend
wisely to win
joe chris brockman here i grew up in
maine so
thank you for being the voice of my
childhood i appreciate that
and all that you've done and what you
mean to the team uh
i imagine you have a great scorecard
collection any any stick out that you
or just a memorable play a triple play
a game or two or what are some of your
memorable
score cards in your collection well
certainly the world series championships
i have
made up for friends and family
and framed um actually my scorebooks i
get to the
new england sports museum which has them
somewhere i think at the
austin garden um but certainly the world
championships
uh and some of the walk-off victories
especially during morgan magic in 1988
when
my good friend joe morgan took over his
manager he won 12 in a row
and 19 out of 20. uh roger clemens
220 strikeout teams certainly would
stand out the rogers signed those
scorecards for me
and so many of pedro martinez's great
performances as well
um so but you have to go back to the
championships i guess because
you know they hadn't had one for 86
years till 2004.
yeah i mean of course uh of david ortiz
so great during that
uh during that stretch and of course his
legendary hall of fame career
do you think a game on the line is he
the guy you'd want at the plate that
you've seen or is it ted williams is it
manny ramirez or nomar
maybe even steve lyons
now it certainly would be poppy number
one because he was oblivious to the
pressure of the big bone but he thrived
in it
part of the reason was he was such a
good hitter and had such a great
knowledge of the strike zone
and great back to ball skills but also i
think his personality was meant for the
big moment
it never got too big for him and uh he
never pressed
he believed in himself so he would
certainly be number one
uh of course i don't go back to 1967 as
a red sox broadcaster but
yes kremsky that year too here in the
yaz and the great clutch hitting
those would be the two i think uh but
poppy fart away
uh because he did it year after year for
the red sox
and he should be a first ballot hall of
famer next year should be unanimous
really
joe casiglione joins the show the voice
of the boston red sox and a deer dear
family friend
travel is not the same obviously in this
new world we live in joe but you've been
a road warrior for years covering the
socks
what american city that is not known for
italian food has better italian food
than people might expect
uh probably baltimore and we
we expect new york to have it but
baltimore has this great little italy
section and uh
uh la scala is a great spot and
chipperellis and there's so many there
and uh about a pre-blocked neighborhood
so
i would rank that uh way up there for
for italian food
we missed the travel you know we're
still doing tv games off the monitors
at an empty fenway park which is very
strange there are about
six to eight people in the ballpark at
those nights where
we are there at fenway calling games off
big tv screens
if there are only six or eight people in
the stands joe just make sure tom
brunanski is not at the plate
when he hits you with a line drive ball
territory
the scary night still got the ball box
on your chest i think
yeah it's good good idea that my dad
decided to keep me there until 1 30 in
the morning when jack clark had a
walk-off home run in the 15th inning
right that was a smart idea don't you
think for my dad
and why you did get checked out by the
red sox medical staffer roger clements
came to your rescue
he got hit with that bullet but uh you
know balls doesn't
usually go there in batting practice
because of the cage but he pulled a long
foul and it found you the ball will find
you as the old saying goes
ball found you in the booth one day what
was it like to catch a foul ball on
air well i picked it up when it stopped
rolling
but still to have a ball come in the
booth while you're calling the game has
that happened to you before i remember
being up there once for a gary pettis
foul ball that somehow made its way into
a booth
it happens maybe uh twice a year because
we're five stories up
directly behind home plate sort of a
tough angle to get a ball in there it
has to
come up uh it can't be a top flight it's
really got to be sort of a
lying shot to get straight back like
that
but i usually you know duck and wait
till it stops rolling and pick it up
and you know i i let my partners be the
heroes and catch the ball
you are you've had some great partners
over the years um so many obviously from
dave o'brien to the legend the late bob
star
uh when you're a broadcaster in your
position what are you looking for
in a partnership when you're calling a
game
well i think basically you've been
somebody that
can relate with you in terms of baseball
that
um you can discuss baseball with because
it's a it's a talking game it's a game
where you talk to the guy sitting next
to you
or uh you know pass hot dogs down the
row
uh somebody's cooperative and listens i
think basically and uh
you know with give and take and
understands the game very well and i've
been blessed to have great partners over
the years starting
my red sex career with ken coleman uh
who's a red sox hall of famer
and there should be in the nfl hall of
fame too for his work with the cleveland
browns
um and then bob starr who was wonderful
uh the late great burley broadcaster as
he called himself
uh we've done the cardinals and the
angels and
uh the then boston patriots
and missouri football rams football
jerry trupiano of course
for 14 years dave o'brien and uh
ken beverett now with the dodgers and i
have a wonderful young partner
and will fleming uh who is in his second
full year with me doing a great job of
course his brother's a long time voice
of the giants
they plumbing one of those guys i got to
see you call some games with
in the booth at dodger stadium was josh
dumel
wow what do you remember about your time
with uh jd out here in southern
california
well that was a lot of fun to be there
with a movie star especially one
who played space man lee in a movie and
uh he's got a great knowledge of
baseball i know he's a minnesota twins
fan
from north dakota i believe in twins
country
and that that's always a thrill when we
have uh celebrities in the booth
um because they really enjoy being there
because they love baseball and josh
certainly is among them
you mentioned him playing bill spaceman
lee and one of the great characters of
the game guys like that can't exist
in today's game can they
well there certainly are characters i
mean if you look at
uh a guy like ricky henderson certainly
is a great character
of course he's been retired for several
years now
in today's game i don't know it's
probably a little bit more
corporate uh maybe not quite the
flamboyant personalities that you have
um not necessarily the nicknames or at
least those that
you know are noted on the air but it
probably is a little bit different now
and i don't know maybe the the bottom
line and all the
high salaries have a little something to
do with being a little bit more
uh buttoned up i guess i get an email
joe
every single time alex verdugo does
anything
if he gets a walk if he gets a hit if he
scores a run i get an email from my dad
talk to me about verdugo season and just
this overachieving bunch this year
because the red sox are having a much
better year
they stumbled as of late but then
anybody in my household predicted
are you surprised at the early showing
that they were able to put out there
yes i'm surprised ben because we had a
terrible season last year
i felt a little bit better after spring
training but the pitching came along
and jd martinez bounced back to his true
form
uh xander bogart is always consistent
and uh
verdugo playing every day brings passion
and the fire uh he's not hit lefties as
well as he did in the past he said
some ups and downs but he's always plays
hard as an outstanding left fielder he's
really mastered the wall
and he's tough to run on i mean he owes
a lot of
wall balls for singles because of his
quickness his ability to play
and his ability to throw but i think
generally the
pitching which has been the starting
pitching has been struggling of late
has been the biggest surprise the
bullpen has been excellent all year
and now red sox have lost six of seven
they're a game and a half back
but the hope is chris sale will be back
sometime
mid to late week next week and that will
give a lift
it's really hard to count on a guy's
coming off tommy john's surgery because
it's not an instant cure but it'll be
interesting to see
uh what chris can do he certainly will
bring a lot of passion a lot of
leadership
and uh he's going to pitch saturday
at scranton against uh for worcester the
triple a club his final rehab start
if all goes well he should maybe pitch
against tampa bay next thursday or
the following day at home so that's
going to be a huge lift for this ball
club
also getting car kyle schwarber from the
acquired in the trade he hasn't played
yet because of the hamstring issue he
had with washington
but that should lift an offense which
has been struggling of late too
well the fact that we're here in august
and we're even thinking about a world
series run for this group i know has my
my dad happy but even my mom happier
because my dad's been in a great mood
all summer listening to your calls and i
was chatting with brockman before you
jumped on he said i have the beer opener
that when you hit it open it has joe's
can you believe it
on the call where have you been in your
travels where someone has come up to you
and said can you believe it or is that
something that people say to you when
they see you out in the world
while they do if they hear me talk that
it'll recognize me fortunately so i
could somewhat feel
incognito but uh that bottle cap opener
was awesome it paid for my daughter's
senior year at boston college
there you go good stuff joe both pitches
were 1-0 pitches you know that right of
course
the uh you know war you have to uh
gerezeria
later came to the red sox the following
year it's back played shortstop
and didn't really yeah but the pokey
reese played it
and the yankee series was a 1-0 pitch
also that was a one-night i didn't
realize that yeah
sierra grounded out yeah i love that
though
that was the ultimate because you know
the red sox had always lost the big game
to the yankees
and when they won game seven and 04 uh
it was extra special
extra special having you on the show and
i love how that bottle cap opener put
katie through college and somehow that
bottle cap
opener kept brockman almost from falling
out of college
in some ways so uh yeah kindred spirits
those two um
joe you're the greatest thank you so
much and i appreciate you in advance for
putting up with my father when he comes
up to
what he calls mecca in september to
promote his book so thank you in advance
for dealing with the big guy
he'll be here and you know now he can
group for the mets too because
one of our all-time favorites rich hill
is not with the mets pitching well
and uh who knows we'd like a replay
play of the 1986 world series oh that'd
be a lot of fun wouldn't it that'd be a
lot of fun
from your lips to god's ears joe you're
the greatest thanks for taking some time
okay benny chris thanks for having me
thanks joe
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here